I found a very important game that I
want to share with you today it's a game
between Vladimir Kramnik versus better
Peter Lake oh not too many people know
that Lake Oh was actually a almost he
was almost gonna win the World
Championship in 2004 in a final around
the 14th game all he needed to do is
make a draw he was winning the match so
if he had made a draw he would have won
the match and the rules were a little
bit different back then you had to win
the match against the champion to
actually win the titles the match ended
a draw seven seven and
kramnik retained his title they didn't
have to play any playoff which was kind
of strange and people felt it was unfair
so that's why they I think changed the
rules in 2006 so let go at this this is
game 14 so they played 13 games
Lecco is winning the match by 7 to 6
all he has to here to make a draw with
blacken is the world champion and this
happened to many many players they came
so close like Schechter you know it was
so close to win a become world champion
he lost to Steinitz in the last game and
many many David Brownstein was very
close and now with you know the example
laco could have been a world champion
very close he was actually playing
really well in this match and just the
nurse coming just was stronger at the
end so that's why I want to show you a
game and show you how you need to play
when you need to win a game must-win
situation so here white must play for a
win and he chose evil c6 in that match
laco was successful with CARICOM so no
difference and E 5
this is the most principled move we if
you don't play this move that means
you're not going for the most principled
lines and let go you know was probably
expecting this because he was playing
caro-kann a lot in that match and
Kramnik decided to take him on on this
so Bishop f5 h4 right the way we see a
very aggressive approach by Kramnik he
needs to win this game a lot of these
lines are very positional and not so
clear how you gonna get advantage there
so here he decided to play this
aggressive wedge for which I have
personally faced myself very strong
French Grandmaster watch allograft
played against me this line so each six
I like this move for block it's a good
move this move was also played by Anand
in a game against Alex Ishiro if you can
look at again that's a very nice win for
black in that line and now if there's g4
attacking the bishop the bishop needs to
move here and here you have to go to d7
and that's the idea because if you go
back to h7 then it's very unpleasant
move is a six creating weaknesses and
Bishop d3 it should be three
and after Bishop d3 there are some
problems as you can see on the light
squares here so that's why black usually
place if they play all the h6 they're
gonna go Bishop d7 92 and here
Lego played the move c5 which is very
typical for this position because you
want to try to put some pressure in the
center and also activate your knight and
now he took D takes e5 right away
kramnik managed to get something complex
and to kind of take a leg away from all
the theoretical work because he was very
well prepared in all the theoretical
lines they would go to Lego was
absolutely fine and he won in a Marshall
with block in a very famous game so he
was very very prepared for this match so
that's why now he had to play moves on
his own and here we place a six and this
is the first dubious move in this
position it's better in this position to
play knight c6 attacking the central
pawn f4 e six
and Bishop c5 95 Queen a flag check and
I think this position is probably equal
black Google Knight g7 and maybe try to
play h5 to get that f5 square here so
this was I think a better way to play
another interesting line here is if
instead of f4 Knight b3 is played which
i think is probably not likely because
the central pawn is weak so Knight takes
e5 Queen takes d5 Bishop g4 it's a very
sharp line because the knight cannot be
taken because of which move queen d1
checkmate
very good so that's why you know just we
should be 5 check 96 some very
unbalanced position White has some extra
pounds but one extra pawn but Black has
two bishops so this is still absolutely
fine for bluff because of the bishop is
very strong but he played it six and now
you need to protect your c5 pawn and you
don't really want to push before because
before a5 and there could be some some
weaknesses so what also I can try to do
to protect it Martin Knight to b3
correct nice move protecting the pawn
that's a very good move you protect upon
and also you're getting ready to develop
your bishop now Bishop takes e5 the
typical idea Knight takes e5 and Queen
a5 check this is this idea is kind of
known so black loses his dark square
bishop but gets the palm back
and now Knight f3 played by Crom Nikias
to bishops and a little bit of space
advantage as well so it's a very
interesting playable position so it was
night 7 and now dubious move played by
kramnik Bishop d3 as you can see this
game was so crucial that both players
are nervous because one player just
needs a draw just to make it draw in
this game he's a world champion and
another player needs to win no matter
what
otherwise he loses his title so it
doesn't get bigger than this so whenever
you see a situation like this where one
game can decide everything that's the
players get really nervous and that's
why you see like in the early stages of
the game they start making some
inaccurate moves so it's it's clear that
in this position white should put the
pawn on h5 here because that way they
will control the g6 square and also they
take away the h5 idea for for block and
then he can follow it up with Bishop d3
so this is a typical idea very useful
move to play but instead she plays
Bishop d3 and now at some point maybe
black could have also played the h5 so
first knight c6 which is normal Bishop
e3 attacking the Queen Queen a did a5
and I played Queen d2 if Queen c2 just
rocks c8 is coming
so he played Queen d2 and now right here
96 was played and which is a fine move
here but very interesting move now black
has here let's try to think about it and
try to see what move plot can really
play here to create some complications
if like Oh play this move it would have
been a different game the rest of the
game was kind of passive and it was just
defending but if you had played this
move you wouldn't have some more
activity and I think better chances to
hold this game and become a world
champion so let's think about it for a
second what black can do here raise your
hand if you have the idea if you think
you see something interesting to get
active that's the idea here somehow you
want to get some activities here
he played 96 which is normal but what
else you can do marking 96 year that's
what he played that's a very normal move
and that's what that's what happened 96
was played but then white was a little
bit better after so that's why I'm
thinking there may be something else yes
before okay very nice yeah let's take a
look at d4 it's a very interesting move
it looks like just sacrificing a pawn
but actually you get some really nice
control of the light squares so first of
all if it takes big with a knight then
if I pawn this week if it takes with the
bishop then you take on d4 and I think
there's some problems you cannot take
with the night your ePHI pawn drops if
you take with the pawn I think some
Queen d5 ideas
Bishop c6 and block is very active okay
so that's why he has to play C takes d4
and I think this position is I kind of
like this position for black because he
has a very clear plan just all you need
to do is just to play for the light
squares so for example one idea that
comes to mind is night before here
threatening to take only force and if
Bishop c6 just a [ __ ] before just
Bishop c6 exchanging Knight comes in
once is 625 idea the position is the
place by itself so that's what this
would have been a much easier way to
play even though you're down upon but
it's just your moves are so much easier
to make which makes it easier to play so
but that didn't happen and so we played
yeah d4 is a tough move to play I mean
if you if you need to make a draw yeah
it's you know it's a tough move to play
but it's it's it's a type of move that
will help you to make that draw much
easier you know because you know we all
know if you need to play for the you
need to make a draw you play for a win
if you play for a draw this was a play
for a draw that's why played for a draw
in this game in and as we know if you
just play for a draw you be likely gonna
lose but if you just plain normal you
play for a win like you're playing in
normal situations you know your chances
are much higher to succeed so 96 is
played now e5 pawn is hanging so Bishop
d4 is forced and now he is getting ready
to play h5 so 94 yeah this is
interesting but it leads to a end game
that it's very close to equality but
slightly passive so again maybe it
wouldn't make sense to play Queen to c7
put some pressure on e5 we need go into
it retake on d4
pantech screen be six play this position
with the queens on the board and some
Bishop b5 ideas typical for you know
French defense we know to exchange so it
would have been interesting to see how
this would have worked out and if Queen
takes you just go back 97 96
I mean maybe white is very slightly
better here but not much this was
another way to play but lay cop just
wanted to simplify and he taught again
Queen b6 is playable move here I
probably would like this limit but just
a little bit more active but he just he
just thought all I need is a draw and I
play good endgame I should be able to
hold this but it's not so easy because
chronic is one of the best technicians
and the space advantage was very
annoying so this is only slightly better
only slightly better and you know
usually positions like this if black
plays perfectly he will make a draw but
it's very difficult to play like so
accurately under that circumstances that
I mentioned because it's just he's just
every move every move could be crucial
not and right away he makes a mistake
night at fourth he tries to be active
but instead he should have just stay put
97
put the knight on c6 then f6 try to get
contra play it's not easy for y to win
this kind of position because black
doesn't have essentially any weaknesses
so when you're a net weaknesses then
opponent doesn't have weaknesses very
hard to win because you know how to get
to the weaknesses so you're not easy to
create one either it's just a space so
this is how you should have played but
instead he opted for nine f4 and now
Lucchesi one immediately we see some
problems now with the C file now Luke is
trying to come to the seventh rank and
we know that the rook shouldn't come to
the seventh rank because that's gonna be
a problem
so night plays h5 trying to create some
culture play here if Knight XZ treats
passive King takes you should be fired
checking e3 can you sound this is really
passive this this is not a way to make
it draw now he will just he will just
continue advancing and yeah this is very
very very difficult position f5 is
coming f6 is coming so White has a plan
black doesn't have any culture play for
it so that's why it's difficult for him
to do anything so that's why he played
h5 trying to get some Kibaki some
activity rook Jiwon it captures he wants
to take back with rook Bishop c6 trying
to block the C file another a lot of
alternatives here but I think all of
them are worse so it looks e8 just take
take pawn takes pawn g7 is hanging you
can get three a knight on the rim we
know it's not very good and yeah this is
a knight is trapped
yeah this is technically last night on
f6
just winning because age five point I
mean you know you don't need to get to
this position when you see a position
like this knight on f6 rook on h6 you
don't need to calculate this kind of
position is gonna be one the night is on
f6 is very powerful so so Roxy it not
gonna work if Knight h3 he didn't try
this just rook to e3 attacking the
knight it takes lightly just to take
when the g7 pawn and try to push the H
panel all the way down so that's the
problem you know you're gonna lose your
t7 pawn here likely and then he's gonna
have outside pass panel make sure that
it's simply gonna march just push push
push
outside passed pawn is very strong we
know that in this kind of end games
because that will give you a very clear
plan of advancing it so that's why I'll
echo didn't want to do it strictly
Bishop c6 and not the best looking move
I mean just to keep the bishop like that
passively to block the C file but that's
that's what she has h6 that's the plan
to open up the G file Knight h5 another
idea is King f8 but it still still
unpleasant for black so he took back of
the night and now b4 Kramnik sees that
he has the initiative so he wants to
increase the pressure now he wants to
play b5 try to knock off the bishop here
and then go rooks e7 activate a rook on
a seventh-round so now he goes a six
preventing it a four he doesn't mind
sacrificing upon that's the kind of move
that you want to find because he
understands that activating the rook on
a seventh rank is much more valuable
than just trying to do anything else
here who would have played the move a
for you think in this position in a real
tournament game with a lot of things on
a line here who would have done this
bold pawn sacrifice to get to C file
then you want now you just thought about
it
let's see
Bishop c6 there Brooke c7 rukon 1/7 we
know it's worth the pun
we know that right Baruch on a 79 games
worth upon and Alec just he keeps a
bishop he keeps the bishop first and
then he comes in extremely unpleasant
position to defend I mean night f7 is
now coming and shall be very difficult
to do anything and if you play this move
it will be followed by which move here
yes
do you see one absolutely correct
now if he takes you take back with this
and you still have a powerful work on a
seventh rank okay very good Martin that
was a good move because you have a
strong rook on a seventh rank you want
to keep it there okay you won't bring
the other one so he didn't do that yes
question Bishop c6 we're here bishop c6
after Knight g5 I think it's pretty bad
you can defend f7 it's defenseless now
because if you go rook to f8 who is
gonna find a winning tactic here very
quickly
okay anybody else know Martin okay again
you found it correct sacrificing the
knife now he takes take back or pin it
to win it right pin it to win it
remember what type of pin absolute pin
right absolute pin is very powerful
you win immediately okay always have to
look for this kind of ideas tactics okay
it's an end game the only thing that you
have to just slowly improve the position
when there are good opportunities you go
for it you don't hesitate okay yes you
have to calculate you have to calculate
I absolutely agree with you yes but
that's not so difficult because one I
mean relatively to I mean three and four
yeah I mean at a very high level I mean
you know you guys can calculate two
formats it's not like it's you know the
moves are pretty natural I mean you get
the rook in you get the knight in when
you got so much pressure on an opponent
what you got to do is now start to look
for tactical ideas that will allow you
to break through do you understand that
part when you have so much pressure and
pieces are very active you have to try
to win with the concrete ideas you
cannot just enjoy the position forever
because then you know your opponent will
probably find some kind of defense so in
some point you have to take some
concrete measures in order to break
through clear okay so April was very
powerful so let go now he realizes that
this is very tough so he found a pretty
decent defense with the King dat Knight
g5 so he taxing the bishop back on the
8th just to defend but as you can see by
just optically by looking at the
position you can tell now how big is the
wise advantage let's evaluate here let's
pause for a second here and I want you
guys to think for two minutes here and
try to see
how big is whites advantage here we know
white has advantage is it slightly is it
big what is it winning
when you're ready just to raise your
hand until we can discuss yes in the
back I think there's a huge advantage if
I count the squares the black will
actually move a piece through right now
well that's actually a very good point
that's another way of determining who
has the advantage in a position like
this when one player has advanced his
pants so much control so much space it
black has very few moves on the board
that he can actually make here you know
he's almost like getting to the point
where it's gonna be a souk salon because
it's just he's not gonna have moves to
move anymore so that's why that's
another way of looking at how big is the
advantage it's you mentioned you say big
or winning or it's huge
okay so it's huge yeah that's close to
be winning I guess another very another
very good point that we need to
understand and remember when we are
trying to evaluate the position first
thing we can also do is just look at the
pieces and compare let's compare the
Knights whose night is better this night
on g5 or the night on h5 it's pretty
clear right his night is on the rim and
it's not good because normally not many
squares one square he has one square to
go to f4 and if you go King g3 is not
going to have that either so that's out
of question let's compare the bishops
the bishop on database 28 I think the
roles are pretty different yeah this
bishop is active looking for some
tactics and this bishop is just parked
here defending the pawn on f7
so that's clear let's get to the rooks
now let's compare the rook on c1 with
the rook on a8 big difference which is
another very important idea a very good
point right there rooks are connected
when the rooks are connected that means
you're doing good when your looks are
not connected that's a sign of you not
doing good actually very you know it's
very simple but yeah that's that's you
know majority of the cases in chess yeah
you will find yourself in trouble when
your king is in the middle of blocking
your connection of your rocks
so the rook on it it's pretty passive
here and rook on h8 is doing some kind
of defense
roll here rukon Jiwon is also has a lot
more opportunities to go around and try
to break through okay okay so we have
some nice possibilities here so but now
he goes b5 I actually wouldn't like King
III you know I think this is interesting
but he didn't want to deal with g6 and
then some night g7 type of rook c8 yeah
this is just yeah maybe not not that
clear why why still has a very big
advantage here but I guess block is
getting a little bit of activity so he
didn't want this so he went for a more
concrete approach with b5 so
Knight f4 again ii dubious move and same
move YC played Knight f4 in this game
both occasions there not to be a dubious
moves so it's better to stay put take
and b6 that's that's a good move to
control the c5 square and if King III or
okay 7 I assumed this is some type of
computer defense here black is trying to
put up here and and looks like you might
be able to looks hopeless but 9 is
coming to f5 which is a which is a huge
improvement white is still ahead but
it's not trivial yet the victory so
that's why he should have played this so
he played night
no he played Knight f4 here and now what
is the correct move here now for black
he missed a moment and this was the move
that might have cost him the title I
mean no guarantee that Lego would hold
the previous position but at least after
the the particular move I feel like
position is hopeless
yes absolutely b6 double exclamation
mark now and white is winning the rook
is coming to the seventh rank I can't
believe he missed that that's a that's
what he missed enough and that's what
custom now Luke on a7 it's game over
here when this rook lands on here this
is gonna hang this pawn is gonna hang
everything the higher position is gonna
collapse I think this was like a shock
for him we're Kramnik played this
because he just he just completely
forgot about the rooks e7 threat again
Luke see it well he played Knight d3 but
rook c8 as well I think fails to which
idea correct
Luke 107 then we know when rope goes on
c7 good things will happen for you so
you just winning here so now he had to
play Knight XD 3 yes Martin Bishop c6
Knight f7 and you lose your rook so
that's what Bishop has to stay here so
take takes rook c8 now trying to
exchange the pair of rocks I mean Luke's
7 is coming so he's got to do that so
what we gonna do taketake go to see what
rook c7 lens we know what's happening
game is over right so he has to go
bishops if he cannot allow the move
Bishop ca the bishop Baruch to c7 so now
my takes absolutely the pawn on d6 is
playing a huge role here continue
excellent
and now night on d6 is very very
powerful
once you can activate your rook this
game will be alright okay rook g1
attacking the week pawn rook h2 the
check
if he has a light square bishop he has a
light square bishop so I was thinking
actually key d2 is probably the same
thing but he opted for the kinky - it
doesn't really matter I think here
approaches okay for and now what is the
plan now King Gandhi - I think is also
another Playboy I mean he's maybe
thinking maybe to activate the king but
here
what's the breakthrough idea yeah you
need to make a break here because if you
take on b7 there's some chances here
because you lose the default form you
need to create a passed pawn very
quickly f4 correct because now if it
takes f5
he takes push now you're threatening to
go e7 and Queen so he has to play this
move only move take take and here this
wins the game because you threaten took
sacrifice let's say he plays here
sacrifice he takes push he comes here
push even though he has two pounds but
you prevail here you're gonna Queen
first and win this game so a very strong
idea again f4 now he's just just all
around very strong play by Cromley very
energetic it just keeping the pressure
on
so he's losing now so check King FG
that's why he went King e - I guess
because now he wants to activate his
King King to g4 rope to d3 attack in the
pond
f-five trying to break through anyway
that's the idea right
check takes and now King f6 first see
you don't want to take a pawn like this
because palm like this is actually an
excellent shield okay for you that he
cannot give you checks from so that's
why you want to get in there now his own
pond it's now creating problem and you
just want to push so it goes here
proposing the exchange of course we
don't want to exchange rocks here
proxy seven now are you thinking about
it six and Brooke seed just announced
the checkmate so he goes here don't rush
now forced mate checkmate in three
checkmate in three let's see who is
gonna find it
yeah when you have a position like this
sometimes it's kind of tricky to find
them mate because you you think
everything is winning but actually you
just need to just find a mate
937 check and he resigned and Kramnik is
the world champion again due to a little
bit of a strange rule that 7-7 champion
retains the title should have been a
play of in my opinion there will be more
fair but yeah check check again yeah you
see which pan now helps you to win the
game this pawn if this pot wasn't there
he goes king c7 black is at least gonna
throw this game so once again we see
once he allowed b6 that's it gromek is
gonna win the game and that's what
happened very strong play by kramnik a
very methodical win and where he just
just improved his pieces you know every
move and just you know was under control
the entire game 7 7 mm again it's 2014
2004 World Championship and it was
chronic vs. like Oh again the lacquer
was just half a game away we can say
yeah one game away from becoming a world
champion and never happened this was and
since then he never had a chance this
was his chance he was at the very end he
did we need to win a candidate cycle and
qualified there but I remember correctly
he defeated Topalov in the final match
to get to this moment and kramnik was
the champion at that time so very very
impressive win by Kramnik and and we see
that he can play he can play very well
you under under pressure which is very
difficult to do even for a very strong
players when there is so much pressure
so many things online and I mean we talk
about world World Championship title
here what's decided on this game so it's
very important to stay calm and try to
play some good moves which he did he
played really good game overall put a
lot of pressure and managed to win do
you guys have any questions about this
game was it pretty you understand now
this game and if you want to find this
game later on this is game number 14
okay so if you want to look at it a
little bit more in-depth this so
remember this is game number 14 from
that title